you think the notion of the anti-hero
has become stronger in our culture now
yeah I think that you know the anti-hero
has been around for a hundred years or
more maybe longer than that actually
maybe all the way back to the Odyssey
because maybe Ulysses is kind of a an
antihero he's most of the time he's
lying
and he'll avoid a fight by telling the
story that disarms the fight although he
gets in a few fights but nonetheless
most of the time he's kind of an
antihero that way because his purpose is
his mission you know is to get home and
it's not to just defeat this person and
defeat this person so he chooses his
battles and I think an antihero has been
with us forever and it will be I mean
characters and you know in a lot of TV
series like Breaking Bad you know
definitely an antihero right in Ozark so
I mean that I think that anti heroes are
all around us and one of the things that
kind of we don't notice is that over the
years the audience starts preferring
anti-heroes on what you know one part of
the audience anyway prefers them to
heroes and they are there for I'm so
familiar to us that we we don't even
notice that they're anti heroes anymore
the other part of the audience I guess
the younger part that's interesting too
because it is I think a younger need
prefers heroes over overt heroes Iron
Man and you know Spider Man and all of
that but I think as people get older and
more experienced of the complications of
life they start realizing that what's
more interesting to them is an ordinary
woman you know working at the post
office becomes a hero against her will
because she she doesn't have a better
choice and that a lot of people can
relate to you know I think the older you
get the more you can relate to that
it's easier to relate to heroes when
you're younger and
think you can conquer the world so I
think there's you know ample room for
both and one of the things that people
don't think about is the fact that oh we
have so many channels now so many ways
in which stories get to us in today's
world that we are hugely sensitive to
little story cues that make us instantly
decide whether we want to see a story or
not you know take take the remote that
allows you to fast-forward you know you
might catch the beginning of a
commercial by mistake because you didn't
fast-forward through it but if even a
second of it catches your attention you
might watch the whole commercial which
is a story right but or you might
fast-forward because you didn't get your
attention and just the fist occation it
takes for a person to do that indicates
how tuned into we are two stories you
know like you turn on your you're
surfing the channels and you run across
the news bit and you hear a couple of
words and you go to the next channel
because I don't hear that story again
I've heard it I heard it enough or I I
can't stand this guy's story you know I
always thought the most typical human
question most characters to human
question is what is your story and if we
if we face people from another planet
that would be our first question it
would be their first question unless
they already knew our story but in our
case we'd want to know what is your
story and first question on a date right
like you're going you finally agree to
go on a date because you want to know
like what is your story and after the
day you go you know I didn't like her
story just didn't like her didn't like
her story didn't get it what happens
with the jury you know the two attorneys
telling stories the journey is to decide
which which of the two stories till they
by which they they don't by so the fact
that we're just surrounded by stories I
think means that storytelling is
probably the number one human science
that everyone needs to learn and know
and the more you know it the better you
are I mean you can tell a story and you
know in a couple of lines like one of
the
the shortest stories in American
literature is Richard Ratigan's I think
it was called the scarlatti tilt and it
goes like this
have you tried living in a one-room
apartment with a man who's just learning
to play the viola that's what she asked
the police when she handed them the
empty revolver you know the whole story
is they are right and one of my favorite
jokes is I want to die peacefully in my
sleep like my grandfather and not like
the passengers in his car in the car he
was driving you know so there's a
three-act story in one sentence and you
know you get it you don't have to tell a
20-minute joke to get the point across
and jokes are jokes or stories
commercials or stories songs or stories
and songs become hugely popular because
they tell a story that millions of
people are relating to at that moment in
time so it's very exciting to be you
know in this world of storytelling and
and seeing masters of it you know coming
along what about the artist is the
antihero whether it's the writer the
musician the filmmaker where their own
backstory and makes them the antihero
and so maybe people gravitate toward
their work more if they knew they had
more of a cookie cutter existence and
they write this great thing well okay
yeah he had a charm life it was easy for
him but if somebody has more of an
antihero sort of arc to their own life
and they're putting out work do you
think people gravitate toward them more
you know I really don't get your
question okay
it's very esoteric and it feels like
you're in a graduate seminar and and I'm
gonna fail because I didn't even get it
oh okay I like I think of it as portrait
of the artist as a young man but yeah
try it again okay sorry I think it's my
San Francisco influences is seeping out
sorry
someone like a John Lennon okay we know
he had his own troubles
you know his troubles with the
government you had different things
going on turbulent love affairs
different things
what it made him more interesting would
we have been as drawn to him
absolutely I don't think I mean that's
really his kind of post story in a sense
because we didn't know who the Beatles
were at the beginning right we didn't
have any idea who they were we just fell
in love with their music and did did it
make them more interesting when we
started finding out that they had lives
and crazy girlfriends and you know
feelings about the government no
actually it made them more human and
which is not necessarily a good thing
for an artist you know the the in the
tradition of the Catholic Church artists
could say they were divinely inspired
and that was cool
I mean that was really good PR that was
like very good spin to have but when you
found out that they really weren't
divinely inspired or that they were
inspired by the devil and that could be
a good spin to but it what happens is
that when a piece of art catches you it
catches you I think completely separate
from its maker because it's it's like a
living thing that suddenly you know
exists I mean I'll never forget my first
reaction to yesterday you know that
amazing song by Paul McCarthy I think
right it's like the minute you finish
hearing the song you go that song always
existed I've never heard it before and
they say it was just release but that is
an eternal song and and that's the power
of a work of art because it's it is now
part of you know it's live it will go on
living for some time we don't know how
long but sometime and that when you
think about it I don't has very little
to do with the artists very little to do
with your knowledge of the artist and
when you start knowing things about the
artist
it starts a bit deflating your view of
the art it's funny because I used to run
a poetry series at Occidental College
and I could invite all my favorite poets
like Bukowski to my series
and I learned that there was a two-edged
sword in some cases I loved it
like pukowski but in other cases I won't
mention when I discovered that the guy
is just a drunken miserable egocentric
guy who who has all these pre-madonna
needs and so on he's just a poet you
know coming to read it at college I
couldn't read his poetry the same way
anymore
and I thought you know thank God I
didn't invite you know some really
favorite poets of mine that I hadn't
invited yet because I don't want to find
out what they're like and that's kind of
the way I feel about it it's like the
artist and his work are two separate
things if you create a great work it
goes its own route and knowing about him
is you know maybe it's a plus maybe it's
a minus but in any case if I had to
choose I'd rather not I'd rather not and
I don't believe it all in a kind of
academic approach that says you have to
understand the artist in order to
understand the art I don't really think
that's true I think you have to
understand the society that the art
appears in before you can understand the
art but I don't think you can understand
you know you need to understand the
artist and I also have a real hard time
dealing with
okay let's revise the past and say that
all of Woody Allen's films are forbidden
because he's a creep you know I I just
have a real problem with that because
those films live on their own in my
opinion and have nothing to do with with
Woody Allen anymore he created them and
I think that's true all the way back to
the beginning of time is that we don't
have to know who Homer is in order to
understand the power of the Iliad or the
Odyssey you know as some professor said
years ago the Iliad the Odyssey were not
written by Homer but by someone else
with the same name you know or the
Shakespeare controversy like who cares
who who Shakespeare was his plays are
amazing and yeah it's curious to know
more about him but nothing I could learn
about Shakespeare would change my mind
about his plays I might change my mad
about his plays based on something else
but not on what I knew about the artist
so that's how I feel about you know
learning about the artist I don't think
we need to you don't think it romantic
romantic sizes who they are let's take
someone like a Marvin Gaye and you and
you hear his stories and he was on top
for a while he wasn't he went away I
guess to Europe or forget where he went
but he came back and we're starting to
get his career back and then tragedy
ensues so does that make us more
attracted to his work not me no no I
mean it might make me curious enough to
look at it but then when I do let's say
I've never heard his work before right
and I I then go listen to it because I
heard something
I hit by a vault into it objectively and
therefore I kind of resent that this is
the way I came to him you know and and
let's say you know Rainer Maria Rilke as
a poet I love like I learned something
about him and I go read his poems and I
read it now through the lens of what I
learned about him and I don't like that
way I like to look at the work of art
itself and I used to teach a course in
which I showed you know examples of
works of art and asked the class what
they thought they were worth and I
showed old Babylonian statues along with
electrical circuitry and along with you
know strange mix of images and a
slideshow and it was very interesting to
see what the class reactions were to
something they knew nothing about
nothing because then during the rest of
the course it was about learning about
these different things which one was
ancient which one was now which was a
work of art on purpose which one is just
interesting looking and artists it
really comes down to artists what people
agree is art and the purity of that is
why I think create create creative
people are superior in a strange way to
the media because that's just a pure
thing like you created this is it
is it something people embrace or not if
they do then you know it's very very
interesting you know it's it's a
successful work of art I'm not saying a
work of art has to be successful because
some works of art are not yet successful
like Moby Dick didn't sell more than I
think 12 copies during Melville's life
and then 20 years after he died it
became a best-seller and that's because
the world of 1906 when it became a
best-seller was ready for it you know it
was right in that world and it wasn't
ready yet for it in Melville's world but
it was the work of art even before that
some people recognized that and saw it
that way
so I mean I all we could go on about
this forever but I I don't like the what
I call the biographical fallacy of
having to know about the artists I think
in fact I think it's a deterrent and
therefore it makes it very clear to me
that when people are trying to reject a
person's art you know career of art
because he did something bad
that just seems nonsense to me links to
me artists are kind of sacred and even
priests do bad things right but they're
still supposedly sacred and we're just
living in this post truth world where
everything you say is fraught with
difficulty because you're going to
offend somebody no matter what and I
think we need to get vibe at so we can
keep talking because otherwise we're all
going to lapse into kind of terminal
silence well today is Esquire or today's
Twitter sort of brouhaha was about the
Esquire cover which and I'm butchering
what it was about but the life of sort
of the white middle-class male team in
the age of social media it shows a young
boy in a room that you know looks like a
middle-class home or whatever okay
that's fine but I guess then yes we're
leaving out many people women included
whatever I'm not totally offended by it
if we figure out a certain group of
people's thoughts motivations whatever I
then maybe we can figure out other
things and
have a dialogue about it but I mean
people were very upset over it and and
so we were in this new age where
somebody's upset about something every
day and as god here's the thing that
everybody you know people are upset all
the time but the reason it feels that
way to us is because of social media and
communications you know this I mean sure
it's always been that way from the
beginning of time people are a set all
the time about everything but we didn't
know that you know it took letters
months and months to get across the
oceans right before that there weren't
even letters how and how much upset can
you show in a smoke signal right but in
today's world every little upset gets
tweeted you know gets emailed gets
texted and people are upset all the time
so we are in a very challenging frontier
of communication where we have to learn
how to continue talking given the fact
that every single word you choose can be
objected to by somebody you know
somebody one of my apprentices read a
screenplay the other day and said she
absolutely loved it but you must take
out the word raping on page 96 because
when raping is used in a non-sexual way
to say the raping of Inca civilization
for example you are going to terribly
hurt somebody in the audience who has
experienced it on a personal level and
truthfully you know the screenplay was
written ten years ago before the me to
move I didn't that particular
sensitivity came to the fore and we're
at the point where there isn't a word
anyone could say that wouldn't upset
somebody somewhere and thank God for
comedians because they they have a way
of turning that into fun you know for us
all thank God but we all need to deal
with that because otherwise we will
lapse into silence or we will lapse into
diatribes which is what what's going on
now we're all we do is yell at each
other and we don't really listen because
we know we can't actually talk you know
three people can't talk to people can
possibly talk I find with you know my
friends like you go with three people
kind of be kind of careful for people
for sure two people can actually talk
even if they're violently opposed to
each other but we're losing the ability
to communicate because you know people
say I was really offended by the tone of
your email what the tone of my email a
cow it's so ingenious that I put a tone
into my email
it was just like typing letters and
there were just six words and you
thought there was a tone well this is
the world we're living in and it's why
it's so challenging
you